hi everybody I'm not sure I need to
introduce the lady who is sitting next
to me I mean we all know who the katana
and can I just say thank you so much I
know you're on a very short visit right
to London so excited to see you I mean
we're so excited glamour we're huge fans
of yours
I'm on a personal level obviously if you
try now that I've met you and actually
spoken to you for like half an hour I'm
literally like you need to be my best
friend right now I'm not even mitting
I'm not even kidding I'm like you are
literally specific as you know how
sometimes you meet you know when you you
meet the people you follow on Instagram
and then you meet them and you're just
like oh my god I want you to be like I
think you are and you literally are the
coolest person so you know we don't like
squeeze your it out so we all know you
know you grew up in the space you live
in Dubai but you have a certain love for
London though don't you like coming here
so much I actually we were just saying
to my family I feel so inspired when I
come here there's definitely dislike
rawness to London it's so cool it's so
edgy so I do want to start coming here
more I feel inspired what do you think
of the beauty in London like the
approach how women approach Beauty I
just feel like women here it's kind of
funny because in California like people
love to wear makeup especially in LA but
in general in the rest of the part of
America they don't really wear as much
makeup and Dubai with lunch for makeup
but in London I feel like every woman
has a general understanding of makeup
and of course I love that I don't feel
like I'm overdressed I don't feel like
you know I feel like in many ways you
can kind of be whoever you want to be
which is so awesome it's so great to
just kind of feel like you can be who
you are and express yourself through
Beauty through makeup and and feel like
you know you don't have to feel like you
to explain yourself or be somebody else
you can just be who you are and that's
really special looking at them from the
outside and also being you know
journalists who've been doing this job
for a long time I look at you and to me
you are you know such an embodiment of
success but also of passion and you know
you really like a female entrepreneur
like a girl boss that like I think a lot
of women look up to and I look up to as
well but I want to take you back to the
beginning yeah so and yours all I don't
want to go back
exercise few years ago but I mean you
obviously started by training as a
makeup artist yeah yeah I trained as an
egg of artist and I trained actually in
LA and I think the one of the biggest
inspirations for me I went to the store
called Mimi's it's been for miss in the
States for being like one of the biggest
beauty stores it's not like a
professional retailers like that really
just kind of like rawness like all like
that it's like it's like that raw makeup
like the pace and you know the glues and
the aesthetics that you kind of go get
and I walked in and they have to swallow
of lashes and I was like oh my god like
I remember I was like the ticket pack I
was like oh my god what is this and I
fell in love and I started buying all
these lashes and I started like gluing
them and cutting them and my sisters
kind of forced me to actually you know
talk to a manufacturer about doing
reaching lashes and the way we started
is actually really funny so I had no
money
CIRA money super broke and I didn't have
money actually to do anything with
packaging so I went to my room and I was
like I'm going to take a selfie this is
new meat packaging this is what it's
going to do I pick a selfie I was a clip
and that was stuff that was packaged and
that was that that was the fact I mean
that's kind of not bad but the idea the
idea is that and actually it's so funny
I don't know if people realize this
before with our previous packaging all
of the lashes in the beginning were
packaged by me me and my family so we
would actually literally like wait do
you remember this it was evident even
remember this but we would literally
like package them ourselves and then
send them to support it was it was very
very simple beginnings but I think
that's really inspiring because not
something you can look at you now and
think like oh she's but you are so
involved
yeah in every aspect of the business I
don't too involved sometimes I think I
joined my team crazy but you know I just
I think that there's still a vision that
I want to carry out and you know that's
why I think a lot of times when maybe we
don't really know what the brand is
doing in the outside because we're just
like on inside so much and you know it's
been well everyone's wearing it you put
lashes on the map again oh I am so happy
but you did know because I remember
again being in the in the industry you
know I of course when I did photo shoot
you know when I would do photo shoots
that make a professional makeup artists
would use lashes on shoot models
actresses on the red carpet but it
wasn't something that in your daily
routine you're a few years back I mean
not long ago
that women would do every day to go to
work and sucide no but you have changed
that you do real but you do realize that
you've had that impact no but it's true
no but it is true and I just but how do
you think this all goes hand-in-hand
with social media with Instagram with
all that it's a very cool time I think
that we live in it so dynamic things are
moving so fast so you know I think like
before where you know you would really
kind of just like wait to kind of you
know find who you are and now you can
just kind of immerse yourself into like
different things you know and I think
even myself I struggled at the beginning
you know I just kind of was like oh you
know I don't want to try so many things
and now I'm like you know what just
retry it I don't like it rub it off I'm
going to look at different pictures of
different people on Pinterest or
whatever and get inspired so I think
like nowadays you can I think you're
almost like you're given permission
almost to really experiment you know
before I like it was almost like you
know I think not accepted you know so
much and Alec individuality and
differences are just so like celebrated
I think it's so cool and I do think
sometimes when I look at your incident
I'm like you're so brave with some of
the silicon or the skincare stuff that
you try it I was like I'm like I'm glad
she's trying that so I don't but like
has there ever been something that you
tried and you're just like oh my god
that just so didn't work like never
again in my life am i doing this yeah
there are some things that I think
especially with hair yeah I tried oh
really
oh no why did they do that but you night
became well you probably have done this
message to where you put egg in your
hair and then you go to shower you don't
realize you actually cook it you thought
yeah oh my god and it turns into an
omelet or a scrambled egg so you have to
like learn how to do that but I mean you
know Beauty beauteous fun we haven't in
a day I think like a lot of times people
take it too seriously and I think that I
wanna I would like to be part of a
change to like make it like a little bit
more lighthearted and warm
I think that's support that it's warm I
think sometimes like beauty and fashion
can be so intimidating you know and it's
like it is like you know you're this
beauty icon in the UK and you're you're
so warm and
you know you're so you're so warmer I
think it's really important to like you
know people need to know that they can
just feel that it you feel that it can
be a part of it not just like it's
something that isn't accessible I think
that's like you know so like that's what
that's what it is now it's like it's how
can
be a part of that too and I think that's
really cool you mean it's like so much
more than just you know looking good
it's feeling good it's like on how you
can like change the structure people's
faces people make money out of uni
there's so many things to it photos what
I'd make if you show up because I said
something to like oppa makeup I do it
for me
yeah like it makes me happy I don't even
make me has an entire different I mean I
did make a little effort for you to say
I did but generally you know I think
someone who doesn't realize that because
I remember when I was a teenager you
know I would always look at fashion
magazines and I've never been a skinny
girl you know I've always been a curvy
girl you've never been skinny and I'd
look at the models and I'd be like well
you know I don't identify with the size
but I looked at the faces and the hair
and I was like I can do that yeah you
know I can do I can try a red lip I can
try you know all right got a I'm not her
diet I want to get my food I want to
drive my life at but don't you feel like
also I think you you're very much like
that about like beauty is so democratic
it is it is occlusive it's very
inclusive now versus like where it was
before it's so inclusive everyone no
matter it's so crazy when you see
makeovers on women who are you know in
nursing homes in their 80s and 90s now
you know versus like people of all
different ethnicities
people who have skin disorders and it
being like an actual expression of me
and boys yeah yeah everything I love
that like Beauty just like literally has
no boundaries and I just think that
that's really special I don't know where
the world of beauty is going to go now
well oh I like that's good that's one of
my that was one of my question where is
it gonna go next we don't know I have a
hypothesis okay tell it hi there it adds
glamour
I think people gone so in select the
artificial beauty like with the filler
and silica I think it's going to get
away from that I think that because it's
gone too far people have gone too much
into the filling people gone too much
into like via those things I think it's
going to go maybe a little more natural
I think it might take some time for that
but I think that's probably what's going
to hit home next word you heard it here
first
now I just ask you about your own makeup
what are the like your absolute faith
your absolute like when you do your
makeup I always have to do half this or
is it like a lip one of your lip colors
or lash or what you always wear no I
have two things that I always wear they
are our products that I always wear just
two things from abroad
I love a lot of our products but I don't
use everything all the time but our
liquid our lip contour and trendsetter I
actually kind of created it for myself
so it's like that thing I use every
single day without fail actually if you
look into my back I have nothing except
for that but that's the one thing you
carry around it and sometimes usually
lotion that's it just because I feel
like at least I'll be put together my
lips but always behind so that's like
the one thing I always have to have and
then my are fair lashes those are your
favorite other my favorite so when I
when I actually have created my night
and I remember like it was like 12 a.m.
by the time when I finished them I woke
up my husband was like correct I just
create these lashes they're going to
mimic lash extensions I love them
they're amazing I could go to in the
morning look if I was like on this like
rush from creating them so those are
like my two favorite products that ever
brand but would you say bestsellers one
I know but that's a thing but I mean
that things the kind of one I did my
little MAC lipstick it was kind of like
my the one that I love your lipstick can
we talk about your lipstick well what I
please can you talk about my lipstick
Hodapp we can you okay I'm so happy that
you did this because I was literally a
money-mad joking today I was really
looking for like a sheen like I don't
always just want to have matte lips but
I also don't want gloss so this for me
I'm like so excited I need America I
don't want to go now but I was looking
for that we can do it on insta like yeah
later I basically just wanted something
just like on top just to give me like
what you haven't well can I have what
you have we'll use them would you agree
to do a little makeup on me first ten
okay well let's do that and then let's
do a separate video with a little makeup
on but can I just say thank you so much
it was so amazing talking to you and I
yes I'm even more of a fan now that I've
spoken to you so thank you so much bye
for more videos like this please make
sure you guys subscribe to glamour UK